Transcriber: Ozay Ozaydin
Burada konuşurken bir şeyleri
başardığımı düşünüyordum.
Yiğit’i dinledikten sonra
aslında o kadar da başarılı
olmadığımı gördüm.
Konuşmamı, Happy Moons’un
başlangıcı, büyümesi,
geldiği nokta ve gitmek istediğim
nokta olarak anlatacağım.
Happy Moons’u anlatırken de kendimizi
anlatmış olacağım.
İlkokul bittikten sonra
iş hayatına atıldım.
Annemler okumamı çok istedi ama
okumaya çok yanaşmadım.
İlk başladığım iş kasap çıraklığı,
sonra oto tamirciliği, sonra kuaför,
en son da bu sektörde
komi olarak başladım.
Komi olarak başladığımda
herhangi bir amacım yoktu.
Tamamen amacım para kazanmaktı.
O zamanki şartlardan bahsediyoruz.
Sonra garson, barmen şef olduktan sonra
askerlik zamanı geldi ve askere gittim.
Şimdi askerlik kısmını biraz anlatacağım
benim için
çünkü kırılma noktalarından biri
ve hikayenin sonunda
5-6 tane kırılma noktası var.
Onlara da değineceğim.
Askere gittim; biliyorsunuz bizim
zamanımızda 18 ay askerlik vardı.
3 ay acemi birlik, 15 ay usta birliğiydi.
3 ayı atlattıktan sonra,
15 ay Çorlu’da bir kolorduda
çaycı olarak başladım.
Şimdi benim yaşımdaki birçok kişi askerde
çaycılığı kebap olarak görüyor.
Ama benim şöyle bir farkım vardı.
Sabah 7'de çay ocağını açıyordum.
Gece 11′e kadar çay, tost yapıyordum.
Çayı tost yaptığım kişiler albay, yarbay,
ondan sonra orgeneral vesaire.
Ve şöyle bir durum vardı telefon çalardı.
Oğlum bana iki çay getir.
Kolorduda 40 tane oda var,
80 tane komutan var.
Sesinden tanıyacaksınız,
hangi oda olduğunu bileceksiniz
ve bu konuda hata yapmayacaksınız.
15 ay, sabah 7 - akşam 11 çaycılık yaptım.
11′de mesaim bittiğinde de
sabah 7′ye kadar 2 saat nöbet tutuyordum.
Yani 4 saat uyku, 20 saat çalışma.
15 ayım böyle geçti.
Askere de gitmeden önce dedim ki,
ben bu mesleği kesinlikle yapmayacağım.
Askerden geldiğimde on beş ayın
öyle geçtiğini düşünsenize.
Hiçbir iş bana zor gelemezdi.
Yani öyle bir askerlik yaşamışım ki benim
önümde hiçbir işin durma şansı yoktu.
Ve tekrar çıktığım noktada Cafe Cadde
Bağdat Caddesi'nde başladım garson olarak.
Ama içimdeki hırsa inanamazsınız.
Volkanlar patlıyor.
Yani köpek gibi çalışasım var böyle
O zorluğu gördükten sonra..
İşe başladım,
sonra dedim ki “bu meslekle ilgili
yapabildiğim en iyi şeyi yapacağım.”
Çünkü on sekiz ay düşünüyorsunuz,
on beş ay çok zorlu bir süreç geçmiş.
Sonra 10 saat mesaide
ben 12 saat, 14 saat çalışıyorum ve
patronun benden böyle bir beklentisi yok.
Mesaime iki saat önce gidiyorum, işim
bitiyor, iki saat daha çalışıyorum.
Patron artık dedi ki: “Bu adam öyle bir
çalışıyor ki bunu yükseltelim.”
Kaptan yaptılar, bir sene sonra
beni şef yaptılar.
Yetmiyor ama daha halen çalışıyorum,
daha halen çalışıyorum.
En sonunda gittim müdüre dedim ki yirmi
dört yaşında beni müdür yap.
24 yaşında seni müdür yapamayız.
Bağdat Caddesi'nin en iyi kafelerinde
birinden bahsediyoruz.
Ondan sonra 3 ay sonra tekrar gittim:
“Beni müdür yap.”
“Hayır, yapamayız abicim.
Yani bu yaşta müdür olmaz burada.”
Üç ay sonra bir daha gittim.
Dedim ki “Beni müdür yap.”
Dedi ki “yok kardeşim senle
anlaşamayacağız,
ben seni müdür yapmıyorum.”
“İyi dedim,” bende şöyle bir duygu var.
O kadar çok çalışıyorum ki,
bu beni bırakamaz.
Böyle bir artistliğim var.
Çıkış verdim adam da kabul etti.
Hiçbir planım yok.
Bir iş bulmamışım.
Ondan sonra çıktım kapı kapı dolaşıyorum.
Herhalde kırk elli restoranı dolaştım.
Abi garson arıyor musunuz?
Yok abi.
Yok
Şef olarak çıkmışım,
garson olarak başlayacağım
Sekiz ay iş bulamadım.
Artistliğimin bedeli.
Sonra bir pizzacı vardı: Sicily’s pizza.
Pizza Hut’la hemen hemen aynıydı.
İki tane şubesi vardı.
Garson olarak başvurdum.
Bir kadın genel müdürü vardı. CV’me baktı.
Orada 4 sene çalışmışım, buradan
daha yüksek bir maaş alıyorsun
ve pozisyonun şef, ama
buraya garson olarak başlıyorsun.
İhtiyacım var, yapacak
hiçbir şeyim yok çünkü.
Yani, artık iş bulamayınca bulaşıkçılık da
yaparsınız, garsonluk da yaparsınız.
İki tane müdür var, bir
tane genel müdür var Sicily’s Pizza’da.
Sahibi de başka bir yerde
kurumsal olarak çalışıyor.
Girdim.
Öyle bir çalışıyorum ki 8
ayda da işsiz kalmışım ya artık
neferi boşaltmışım.
Üç ay sonra iki tane müdürü
çıkardı genel müdür.
Dedi “maliyetler çok yüksek,
iki müdür maaşı ödeyemiyoruz.
Seni müdür yapacağım.”
Tamam dedim ya hedefime ulaştım.
Onları çıkardı ben müdür oldum,
ama pizzacıdan bahsediyoruz.
Mevla Hanım hamileydi.
Altı ay sonra dedi ki “ben çıkıyorum,
artık doğum yapacağım.
Seni genel müdür yapacağım.”
Abi süper.
Daha ne olabilir yani?
Hedeflerine yavaş yavaş ulaşıyorsun.
Yalnız pizzacısın, genel müdürsün
başka müdür yok altında.
Ya neyin genel müdürlüğü?
Ama pozisyon istediğin pozisyon mu?
Evet.
Amacım para filan değil.
Genel müdür oldum.
Dediğim gibi patron başka bir yerde
profesyonel olarak çalıştığı için
işle ilgilenmiyor,
herşeyle ben ilgileniyorum.
Abi para gönder.
Pizza bitti, pizza kaşarı bitti.
Hüseyin Para yok.
Kredi kartından gidiyordum,
Migros'tan peynir alıyordum.
Geliyordum, satıyorduk.
Akşamki kasadan parayı cebime koyuyordum.
Bir gün sonra yine böyle
böyle bir zaman geçti.
Yirmi beş yaşlarındayım.
Yahu dedim ki adam büyümüyor,
adam dükkanı geliştirmiyor.
Her işi ben yapıyorum.
Yani niye yapayım ki?
Burada da bir kırılma noktası var.
Dedim ki kendi işimi yapacağım.
Düşündüğüm, yapmak istediğim
ne varsa ben yapacağım.
Cebimde para var mı? Para yok.
Dedim ki para biriktireceğim bu arada,
biriktirebildiğim kadar.
İki sene boyunca İstanbul’da
Hürriyet ve Sabah gazetesinin eklerindeki
devren cafe, restoran barın
ne kadarı varsa gittim.
Dedim abi 5000 liram var geri kalan neyse
altmış, yetmiş, seksen, yüz,
beş beş senetle ödeyeyim.
Kardeşim böyle şey mi olur dedi bir firma.
Böyle böyle 60-70, en son Kadıköy’deki
ilk dükkana gittim, ilk şubemize.
Teoman abi dedim, böyle böyle
devir ediyormuşsun.
Yüz bin liraya devrediyorum.
5000 liram var geri kalanını
senet yapacağım.
Oğlum manyak mısın?
Böyle ticaret mi olur?
O kadar da ölmedik dedi.
Tamam dedim, aklında olsun.
Gittim tekrar örüyorum, iş ararken de
konseptlere bakıyorum orada.
Çünkü artık dükkan açacağım, nasıl bir şey
olacağına da karar vermem gerekiyor.
3 ay sonra aradı Teoman Abi gel konuşalım,
benim dedi üçte iki hissem var.
Üçte biri de Fevzi’nin üçte iki hissemi.
sana 60 bin liraya vereyim.
5000 lira öde, geri
kalanına senet yapalım.
Tamam abi dedim bana uyar.
Aldığım dükkanın elektrik, vergi borcu,
SSK borcu hepsini de üstüme yıktı.
Ama kabul ederek yaptım bu işi.
Ondan sonra, dükkan aldım.
Evde dükkan ararken çizgi film izliyordum.
Simpsonlar’ın çizgi filmi.
Mutfakları siyah beyaz zemin
koltuklar da kırmızı.
Kurulumu tamamen bunun
üzerinden yapmıştım.
Dedim ki.
Bunun üzerinde ne olabilir konsept?
O zaman araştırırken
Amerikan Dinerlar var.
İnternetten Amerikan Dinerları arıyorum.
Duvarlarda resimler neonlar vs.
şudur budur, tamam.
Kafamda dükkanı ararken
konsept belli zaten
ama daha isim ve logoyu belirlememişim.
Dükkanı aldım.
Ailemdeki ne kadar altın bilezik vesaire
var verin dedim dekorasyon yapacağım.
Benim bacağımda şeydi koltukçuydu,
döşemeyi de onlara yaptırdım.
Kırmızı koltuk, sonra yerlere seramik.
Ondan sonra internetten resim indir,
duvarlara as.
Maliyeti mümkün olduğu kadar
ucuz tutuyorum.
Sonra dedim ki isim ne olmalı?
Çünkü internette araştırdığım bütün
isimler,
işte Amerikan Diner tarzı olanlar.
Adams, Johns, Bobs, hepsi İngilizce.
Benim adım Hüseyin.
Irak’taysam iş yaparım ama Türkiye’de
Hüseyin ismi yabancı bir konseptte tutmaz.
Dedim ki başka ne olabilir?
E soyadımı İngilizce’ye çevireyim dedim.
Aymutlu’nun İngilizcesi
Moon Happy yapıyor.
Moon Happy, Moon Happy,
kulağa çok iyi gelmiyor.
Başka ne olabilir?
Mutlu Ay ters çevireyim soyadımı.
Mutlu Ay Happy Moons,
Happy Moons, Happy Moons.
Happy Moons ismi kulağıma çok hoş geldi.
Sonra internetten İngiliz şövalyelerin
kalkanlarını gördüm.
Hemen bir grafikçi arkadaşa dedim ki
bunların kılıçlarını çıkar abi
mızrağı da çıkar
ortasına kırmızı beyaz bir dama yap.
Happy Moons ismini de ortaya yaz.
Baktım çok güzel de bir iş yaptı arkadaş,
süper.
İsimle ilgili bir hikaye anlatayım size.
Şaşkınbakkal şubemiz var.
Kazım Kula’nın hemen arkasında
kapıda müşteri karşılıyorum,
Öğlen vakti bir kadın müşteri geldi,
3 arkadaş.
Girerken çok heyecanlılar.
Bunu Amerika'dan nasıl getirdiniz?
Çok büyük bir başarı.
Gerçekten çok büyük bir iş yaptınız.
Ondan sonra ben bu markayı da Amerika'da
da biliyorum, çok güzel filan dedi.
Ondan sonra dedim söyleyeyim
mi söylemeyeyim mi?
Ama bende de böyle şey vardır,
doğruculuk vardır.
Yani onu gizlemek bana yalan gibi geliyor.
Hanımefendi dedim, benim bu soyisim kendi
markam, ben yaptım
yani oradaki hayal kırıklığına
inanamazsınız.
Dedim ki bundan sonra söylemesem
mi acaba ticari olarak
çünkü bir başarısızlık olabilir bu.
Yani Türk markası, soyadını koymuş,
ameleye bak.
O zamanki yüz ifadesi tamamen buydu.
Ondan sonra, yaptım dükkanı açtık,
yerleşimini yaptık.
Çok güzel bir dükkan.
Bizim sokakta Bahariye caddesinde
5 6 tane dükkan var.
Hepsi iş yapıyor.
Bizim dükkan iş yapmıyor.
Abi dükkan güzel, karşı taraftan güzel,
hizmet güzel, ben bu işi biliyorum.
Nasıl yapmaz?
Odur budur.
Rakiplere bakıyorum, onlara bakıyorum,
Bir yerde hata mı yapıyoruz?
Bütün herşeyi tekrar tekrar çek ediyorum.
Senet zamanı gelmiş maaşları ödeyeceğim
hiçbiri için param yok.
Ailemdeki bütün paraları da almışım.
Ne yapcam, ne yapcam, ne yapcam ama yani
yapabildiğim bütün fikirleri,
bütün herşeyi, piyasayı,
her yeri olabildiğince araştırıyorum.
Bir gün hiç unutmuyorum Kadıköy’den
çıkmışım, dolmuşa binmişim.
Eve gelmişim kapıyı çalmışım ve
aradaki zamanı hatırlamıyorum.
Yani dolmuşa nasıl bindim, nerede indim,
o kapıya nasıl geldim
hiçbirini hatırlamıyorum.
O kadar yoğun bir stres, baskı, ondan
sonra batma duygusu vesaire.
Ama düşünmeye yoğun bir şekilde bir
kurtuluş, bir çaba, bir şey arıyorum.
Yani bir ilaç arıyorum
ne yapabilirim diye.
Tekrar Bahariye Caddesi’nden inerken sol
tarafta bir tane ayakkabıcı
tenzilattan satış ayakkabılar şurdan
şuraya düştü diye.
Tamam dedim.
Hemen bir brandacıya gittim.
Hamburger, kola 5 lira yaz abi
dedim ve 4 metre olsun.
Dükkanın bütün cephesini kapatsın.
Hemen yaptırdım, sabah 10′da
astım brandayı.
On birde dükkan ağzına kadar doldu.
Ağzına kadar doldu.
Siparişleri yetiştiremiyoruz.
Ondan sonra tekrar, ondan sonra tekrar,
ondan sonra tekrar dükkan hiç boş kalmadı.
İçeri gelen müşterilerin
satışlarına bakıyoruz.
Hamburger, kola sayısı çok az.
Orada şunu öğreniyorum ki.
Kaçırdığın nokta oymuş.
Müşteri fiyat odaklı bir müşteri tamamen
Kadıköy’de dershane ve öğrenci
yoğunluğu var
ve dükkan o sokağa göre güzel.
Pahalıdır diye içeri insanlar girmiyor.
Tek yapmam gereken fiyat yazmakmış
Bir buçuk ayın çektiğim çileyi vesaire.
Yani tek nedeni kaçırdığım
küçük bir ayrıntıymış.
Her neyse sonra işler çok iyi gitti,
ikinci dükkanı açtık,
üçüncü dükkanı açtık.
Tekrar bir karar.
Rakiplerimiz 5 6 7 benim bütün
dükkanlarım ara sokakta
görünmeyen noktalarda.
Ondan sonra rakiplerim büyüyor
ben büyümezsem küçüleceğim
ama mükemmeliyetçilik var,
hizmet kalitem düşerse, şu olursa,
bu olursa diye
Amerika’ya gittim.
Orada 300 tane 500 tane şubesi olan
markalar ne yapıyor, nasıl kontrol ediyor,
nasıl büyüyor, nasıl denetliyorlar.
Gittim bakabildiğim kadar hepsine baktım.
Operasyon kitaplarını aldım,
Türkçeye çevirdim, hepsini
inceledim vesaire, geldim.
Yönetici arkadaşlarla dedim ki biz
büyüyeceğiz çünkü AVM'ler büyüyor,
caddedeki sokaklardaki dükkan
sayısı artıyor vesaire.
Bu treni kaçırmamak lazım.
Sonra dedik ki öyle bir şey yapalım ki
bir aylık garsonla on yıllık garsonun
hizmet kalitesi hemen hemen aynı olsun.
Müşteri memnuniyetini ortalama
olarak yakalayalım.
Büyüyelim, oradan gol yemeyelim
ne yaparız?
Dedik ki müşterinin beklentisi ne?
Kapıdan girdi mi hoş geldin diyeceksin.
Olmazsa olmaz bire yaz bunu.
Müşteri oturduğunda
beş dakikada menü vereceksin.
Bunu da yaz.
Sipariş aldıktan sonra beş
dakikada içeceğe gelecek, yaz.
15 dakikada maksimum 20 dakikada
yemek gelecek.
Bunu da yaz.
Hesap istediğinde beş dakikada gelecek.
Giderken iyi günler, iyi
akşamlar diyeceksin, yaz.
Bu servis adımlarını yazdık.
Tamam dedik.
Bu güzel.
Bunları nasıl denetleyeceğiz?
Bu nasıl bir sisteme dönecek?
Ayda dört kere gizli müşteri bizden
bağımsız bir şekilde gelecek.
Bunları tek tek sorulacak.
Ondan sonra o şube müdürüne bununla
ilgili prim vereceğiz.
Şubeye not vereceğiz.
O işi iyi yapan garson da
bundan prim alacak.
Herkese havuç var ve sistem var ve
birbirini denetleyen bir şey var.
Ben olmasam da kim ne yapıyor
herkes biliyor.
Bunun üzerine bir kurgu yaptık.
20 dakikada çıkabilecek yemekleri koyduk.
Daha iyisi var ama yemeği 20 dakikada
çıkması lazım,
porsiyonların büyük olması
lazım vesaire.
Sistemi kurduk.
Bu şekilde de büyüdük.
Şu an ki geldiğimiz nokta.
60 şube.
3000 çalışan.
Türkiye'nin dışında Erbil'de
Azerbaycan da var.
Bu geldiğimiz nokta.
Kadıköy Bahariye Caddesi'nde 5 binde
başladığımız şu anki geldiğimiz nokta.
3 bin çalışan, 60 şube.
Bundan sonra yapmak istediğimiz Amerikayı
yurt dışına o kadar çok gittik ki dedik
ki evet bizden daha iyileri var ama biz
bu kadar fokus yaptığımız, bu kadar
içinde olduğumuz bir işin ve severek
yaptığımız bir işi
yurt dışına taşımamız lazım.
Onun için bundan sonraki hikayemiz
Amerikada zincirleşmek,
İngilterede zincirleşmek, ondan sonra
Rusyada ve Ortadoğuda zincirleşmek.
Bunlarla ilgili pandemiden önce bir adım
attık ama pandemi girince durduk.
Bundan sonra tekrar bir aksiyon aldık.
Şimdi kırılma noktalarına geleyim.
Askerde 15 ay çok zor bir şartlarda
askerlik yapmak,
benim birinci kırılma anım.
İyi ki yapmışım askerliğimi ve o şartlarda
yapmışım diyorum.
İkincisi, müdür olmak için patronuma kafa
tutmuşum
ve müdürlük olmazsa yapmam demişim.
Bu benim ikinci kırılma noktam.
Geri dönüp kontrol ettiğimde.
Üçüncüsü genel müdürlük yaptığım yerde
patrondan daha iyi yapabileceğim için
kendi dükkanımı açma kararı almak.
Dördüncüsü, büyümek için doğru zamanı,
doğru treni beklemişim, görmüşüm
ve büyüme kararı almışım.
Benim geriye dönük baktığımda bu.
Şimdi küçük bir şekilde
Hüseyin Aymutlu’yu anlatayım.
Şunu atladım galiba.
İlkokuldan ayrıldıktan sonra askerden
geldiğim ve ilk yaptığım şey
dışarıdan ortaokul ve
liseyi bitirmek oldu.
Şimdi Hüseyin Aymutlu, içe kapanık.
Gençliğimden bahsediyorum.
Ondan sonra dışarı çıkmayan
asosyal bir çocuk.
Arkadaşları çağırsa da dışarıya çıkmayan,
mahallede çok az top oynayan,
kendi içinde bir dünyası olan bir çocuk.
Bir gün Karaköy'den Kadıköy'e gelirken
vapur iskelesinde bir kitapçı var.
Orada “Sınırsız Güç” diye bir kitap.
Antony Robinson’un.
Belki bilenler vardır.
Tam almak istediğimde,
anneme söylediğimde,
annem vapur kalkıyor gel
dedi ama içimde kaldı.
Sanki benim anahtarı oymuş gibi
verdiği tamamen duygu buydu.
Yani o kitabı aldığımda
ben anahtarımı bulucam.
Çünkü içe kapanık, sümsük yani dışarıda
çok böyle bir ortamda
kafasını eğen bir tipim.
Döndüm evden Karaköy'e gittim,
o kitabı aldım.
Hayatımı değiştirdi de demek
bence doğru olur.
O kitabı aldım, içindeki kişisel gelişimle
ilgili çok ihtiyacım olduğu
bana o kadar örtüşen şeyler vardı ki o
yılda o kitabı okumak beni ondan sonraki
davranışlarım, tutumum, yaklaşımım,
çabam her zaman çalışkandım ben.
Ama her zaman kendimi geliştirmekle
ilgili doğru kararlar almayabiliyordum.
Oradan geldiğimde Teksas, Tommiks’leri
bir kenara koyarsanız
beş yüzden fazla kitap okumuşumdur.
O kitap sayesinde, ne zaman sıkışsam,
pazarlamayla ilgili, inovasyonla ilgili,
stok maliyetiyle ilgili, muhasebe ile
ilgili her zaman bir kitap okudum.
Her tıkandığımda ve her çözemediğim
sorunda bir kitaba dayandım.
Bu kitapların hepsi bana farklı
pencereler açtı.
Rekabette olsun, yenilikte olsun, gitmem
istediğim noktada olsun vesaire.
Onun için o kitap bir dönüm noktası,
onu atlamışım.
30 yıllık bir iş hayatımı 18 20 dakikada
anlatmaya çalıştım.
Dolu, kırılma, küçük fay hatları var.
Onları burada anlatsam çok uzun sürecek.
Onun için benim hayatım bu.
Happy Moons’la, Hüseyin Aymutlu
aynı zamanda büyüdü
ve birbirine destek olarak büyüdü.
Beni dinlediğiniz için teşekkür ederim.